Die area 51 oder fifty one im us bundesstaat nevada eine geheime militärbasis auf der immer wieder mysteriöse
aktivitäten beobachtet werden unzählige
Verschwörungstheorien oder sind es gar. Keine ranken sich
um diese location und das us-militär und die regierung halten sich bedeckt was
Geht also wirklich ab ist die area fifty one ein ufo
Landeplatz oder ein testgelände für geheim jets krieg substanzen fiction herzlich willkommen
Erst einmal vielen dank für diesen coolen dem vorschlag bei whatsapp wir da hin kommt dass, er vater am ende des videos
vor diesem einen spektakulären abend im mai
1989 hatte die öffentlichkeit noch nichts von dem
Abgelegenen militärischen sperrgebiet in nevada mitten im nirgendwo gehört nur die silhouette von
Dem, geheimen informanten war im fernsehinterview zu sehen schließlich wollte dennis
So nannte, er sich nicht erkannt werden ergab sich als ex mitarbeiter der nellis air force base aus die rund
150 kilometer vor las vegas entfernt ist und er hatte kuriose dinge zu berichten unter anderem von
neuen fliegenden untertassen
außerirdischen ursprungs
Alien raumschiffen also die er als physiker zusammen mit anderen forscherinnen. Und forschern untersucht haben wollte. Robert
Lasso der echte name des zeugen wollte sich vor allem, um den anti materie antrieb der drei meter hohen
Flug scheiben gekümmert haben, er sollte ihn nach bauen. Und so das berichtete, er später in einer neunteiligen
Dokumentation auf demselben fernsehen.de sender class tv er hatte es auch schon einige testflüge
geben
Lassen behauptete außerdem dass die us regierung hinter allem stecke und area fifty one
Als location benutze um mit einer großen grauen
Schweizerischen spezies in kontakt, zu treten und technologien auszutauschen die aliens hätten sehr
Kleine münder. Und nasen dafür bei extrem große köpfe. Und augen ja ihr könnt euch vorstellen was diese story weltweit auslöste es gab. Einen regelrechten
Ufo und alien haid werden dort schlimme
allen
Experimente durchgeführt ist die area 5 gewann die
Spielwiese für ufo tests auf unserer erde genau diesen hype hatte die us regierung. Jahrelang zu verhindern versucht die
Militärbasis war lange zeit wohl mit eines der krassesten geheimnisse überhaupt teilweise hatte die
amerikanische regierung es sogar
bestritten dass die anlage überhaupt existiert obwohl es sogar fotos aus dem weltraum gab die die basis deutlich zeigte
1994 dann, ein erster hinweis dass area 5 die wand tatsächlich existiert existiert doch das
geschah auch mehr oder weniger not
Ehemalige arbeiter hatten geklagt dass sie auf dem stützpunkt giftige gase. Eingeatmet hatten doch bis
Heute sind die offiziellen informationen die
zur mädels range herausgegeben werden
Mehr als dürftig in einem statement der airforce heißt es
Zitat, gewisse aktivitäten und operationen die amneris range in vergangenheit. Und gegenwart durchgeführt werden bleiben unter verschluss
Und können nicht öffentlich diskutiert werden
2013 sprach die us regierung das erste mal offiziell von der existenz des testgeländes sie, veröffentlichte damals
Geheime unterlagen in einem 400 seitigen dokument in dem. Alle flugzeug tests seit den 50er. Jahren aufgelistet sind doch der mythos
Um area fifty one wird bestehen bleiben
dafür sorgen raketen abfangjäger schwer bewaffnete sicherheitsleute versteckte mikrofone sensoren
Und kameras die region ist ein militärisches sperrgebiet
Und eindringlinge werden sofort festgenommen bevor area 5 gewann zum hochsicherheits gelände wurde
Diente sie als ausweich. Landeplatz der airforce der ausgetrockneten salzsee
Eignete sich hervorragend als landebahn außerdem sorgt auch das benachbarte
atombombentest gelände dafür dass sich kaum jemand in dieser region verirrt
Und so nutzen die ce und die erforscht das gelände um die ganzen projekte überhaupt zu testen beispielsweise
die
u2 ein spionage flugzeug das für den
Kalten, krieg entwickeln worden war auch das nachfolgemodell der u2 wurde je getestet die a12 die mit dreifacher schallgeschwindigkeit
Unterwegs ist heutzutage ist sie allerdings. Noch, mehr los mehr als 20 anders 30 wohnhäuser
und drei start und landebahnen befinden sich hier eine von ihnen mit rund sieben kilometern bis zu
1500 menschen arbeiten hier täglich doch was genau
machen sie laut den
Zahlreichen verschwörungstheorien arbeiten sie oberirdisch an irgendwelchen militär projekten aber das nur zur tarnung
doch eigentlich soll dort in einem riesigen tunnelsystem unter der wüste an
außerirdischen technologien geforscht werden seriöse expertinnen und experten
Bezweifeln dass die anlage werde zwar zur erprobung neuer technologien genutzt diese seien allerdings alle irdisch und nicht
Außerirdisch die massenhaften ufo sichtungen in der region seien, alle mit den vielen flugzeug
experimenten zu erklären und insider behaupten sogar dass die verantwortlichen der iaa 15 solche verschwörungstheorien
inzwischen sogar ganz lieb sein denn diese würden die menschen von den tatsächlichen
Geheim, projekten ablenken so würden ab und an auch extra
Lasershows abgehalten, um die ganzen, uwe jäger in der region weiter, zu verwirren, und auch der zeuge von damals
So etwas lasse sich schnell als unglaubwürdig seine angeblichen
Universitätsabschlüsse waren erfunden zudem zeigten andere
Physiker dass er in sachen ufo bau nur wenig, ahnung hatte später wurde, er dann auch. Noch in las vegas wegen zuhälterei
Verurteilt, er hatte eine videoüberwachungsanlage in einem bordell installiert. Also robert lover fake und auch. Alle anderen
videoaufnahmen und das bildmaterial
Haben, sich als fake herausgestellt ehrlich
Gesagt weil der area 5 die wahren kann man nicht entscheiden was war und was fähiges hier wird unter strengsten geheimhaltungs bedingungen gearbeitet
Das gelände ist militärisch ist wind also der verteidigung der usa über das was da passiert weiß nur, ein kleiner personenkreis
Bescheid ja man kann hier nur glauben oder eben nicht
Dran glauben ja wenn es also neue belege geben sollte oder andere. Hinweise werde ich natürlich darüber berichten und wenn er kein video dazu
Und so allen anderen dem verpassen wollt die youtube abo box funktioniert. Ja einfach nicht
Dann, endet mich bei whatsapp nur dann verpasst ihr kein video wie whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
noch vor allen andern vom neuesten video
Garantiert einfach hier draufklicken. Und zur begrüßung habe ich noch
ein kleines geschenk für euch ansonsten unbedingt meinen schwesterkanal
pixum
Socialmedia abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt wie zum beispiel die
Hintergründe über den volks lehrer der an einer schule in berlin gekündigt wurde, weil, er unter anderem auf youtube
Verschwörungstheorien verbreitet hat. Dafür auch hier klicken aber nicht
Genau, die glocke vergessen wie geht's weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken. Ufo sichtung sehr sehr spannend bis. Dann
bleibt dran